this week on american horror story
this
is not a mess okay enough of that well
we have another episode of american
horror story double feature and this one
is a giant flashback which asks the
questions are sunsets gay do something
totally gay like watch [ __ ] sunset
join me as we go over episode 4 blood
buffet its latest theories and details
you missed along the way but before you
do make sure to like and subscribe
seriously only 14 of you are subscribed
because i got you covered for everything
ahs the flashback begins five years ago
in october the chemist is looking for a
quiet place to set up her lap and we see
here dennis o'hare's character holden
vaughn acting as her realtor which is
interesting because in episode 3 he
tells chief burleson that he's a famous
interior designer so it's likely
somewhere in this five-year period
holden takes the black pill and pursues
his dream of becoming a famous interior
designer becoming rich along the way he
tells burleson he owns an apartment in
new york and the only reason he's up in
p-town in present day is one of his
greyhounds which we'll later see two of
in this episode passed away and he can't
stand being where his dog died holden
isn't stupid and realizes this chemist
with a phd from harvard is likely in
town looking for a secluded home to cook
meth it's not meth she's cooking it's
something far more mysterious the mickey
of five years ago seems pretty similar
to the mickey of today hustling men at
the muse like holden vaughn who tells
him to get lost but the chemist sees a
use for him bringing him back to her
place she sees that he could be one of
her test subjects when he expresses his
dreams of becoming a famous writer
something we've known from previous
episodes well it just so happens the
chemist used to be a biochemical
engineer who worked with the us military
on a secret project to unlock the
creative parts of the brain well
actually it was to shut off those
creative parts because they wanted
soldiers to become mindless war machines
but in order to do that you'd first need
to figure out how that part of the brain
works but to lock up the creative mind
we also have to understand how to unlock
it this is our first confirmation that
the chemist has ties to the us military
and with death valley the second part of
double feature heavily featuring the us
military the chemist and the black pill
are the strongest links we currently
have that connect the two parts in the
promo material we even see a pale
creature and alien ingesting the black
pill we also don't know what exactly is
in one of these pills could the missing
ingredient be something not of this
world but then that begs the question
how has she been able to make these
pills for the last five years without
running out of this special alien
ingredient unless of course she herself
is not of this world in episode 3 she
tells mickey and belle noir that if she
were to die the secret of the pill would
die with her we learned that the chemist
was involved in testing the black pill
on primates and that it stimulates the
occipital lobe of the brain the part
which controls creativity users who take
it can experience 10 50 or even a
thousand times the function of this lobe
while on the drug the downside is that
some of the apes became highly
aggressive and tore the other apes limb
from limb it's almost like the
non-creative ones can tolerate their
lack of talent
until they're confronted with it
then their mediocrity drives a man
mickey is like hell no i ain't taking
that drug and the chemist offers him 50
bucks for any test subjects he brings to
her so that night while he's with tb
karen he asks her if she has any talent
to which she says
no i'm [ __ ] inside and now can i have a
hit so karen's out of the mix but when
mickey finds the man who will later
become the pale creature singing he
quickly ushers him to the chemist the
fact we're never given his name have led
some to believe he might be related to
another character on the show perhaps
ursula but the evidence is still pretty
thin on that one at the local bookstore
bel noir does a live reading of her
latest book martha's cherry tree an
erotic retelling of martha and george
washington's relationship which even
includes a threesome with ben franklin
it's the perfect name for the book as
cherry tree has a double meaning one of
them being sexual wink wink cherry tree
and ties into the fictitious tale that
six-year-old george washington was
caught cutting down a cherry tree by his
father and famously tells him i cannot
tell a lie well the book isn't exactly a
hit with the three people in attendance
and especially her husband rey who is
just a gem of a man your books gross me
out do you want me to suck some [ __ ]
while i'm in there it's that you're weak
and scared
and boring now that i have to be with
you all the time it's intolerable this
marriage
is over i don't like him and i knew
things weren't going to turn out well
for him as soon as i saw this ring with
the letter r on it i've been looking for
this ever since the preview footage
showed a dismembered hand with this same
ring wash ashore after being verbally
abused by her husband belle goes out on
the town where she's approached by
mickey the two soon hit it off and bell
gets high off meth kicking it on the
dance floor meanwhile the pale man has a
negative reaction to the black pill he
ironically orders a bloody mary before
puking it out and noticing his hair
falling out belle asks for more drugs
but mickey offers her something better
taking her to the chemist to realize her
dreams of becoming a famous writer belle
also asks him why he doesn't take it to
which he explains it's not for me
it only works for people like you
artists this mentality will change over
the course of five years when in episode
two we see mickey eventually take one of
these pills the chemist explains that
there will be side effects but bella is
willing to do anything and even agrees
to be monitored and studied by her that
night she finishes an entire book while
high off the drug it's reminiscent of
what happened to harry when he was doing
his work rey arrives later that morning
telling his wife he spent the night with
another woman and continues to berate
her this is the last straw for belle who
smashes a wine bottle slits his throat
and gorges off his blood she'll later
tell the chemist that it was like she
could smell the blood through his skin
the pale man turns more and more into
gollum visiting the chemist afraid of
how the drug is affecting him he says
he's freezing cold and the chemist shoes
him away telling him to get a coat we're
back at lark's shop which was actually
hinted as having a fine vintage rack in
the radio promotional material
hot tip that tattoo shop on commercial
street has a truly iconic vintage rack
so we get this great coat origin story
as lark explains there used to be a lot
of gay people here but when they left in
the late 80s they left their fashion
with them at the graveyard which seems
to be the pale man stomping ground he
performs his first kill on an
unsuspecting mourner as a vegan this is
very surprising to him the chemist tells
him that his urge to kill is caused by
two things a lack of minerals in the
body and rage a rage fueled by the
hatred he has for the world for giving
him dreams that were too big the
talented pill takers have this rage too
however for them their rage is caused by
their own arrogance and certainty that
they're better than everyone the pale
man's rage however is much darker and
more intense the chemist has to pull a
gun on the pale man whose rage boils
over and it's here she exclaims that 9
out of 10 people who take the pill will
turn out like him this may explain why
in episode 3 she turns down an offer
from ursula to mass distribute the pill
and make millions we still don't know
the chemist's motivations with the pill
she doesn't seem to be doing it for
money doesn't seem to want to give it to
everyone and she seems genuinely
interested in unlocking that creative
part of the brain and not using it for
100 evil like the us military did so
this motivation is something that will
likely be a big reveal later in the
season the pale man kills yet again as
we fast forward two years or three years
before the events of episodes one to
three belle has permanently moved to p10
where she goes for a trendy new look at
lark's establishment lark tells belle
that she's been on the pill for six
months her talent manifesting in tattoos
and she also tells about how she killed
her ex-boyfriend on the beach that seems
to happen a lot around here she even
shows off her fang teeth which belle is
like i'll have what she's having with
her new look belle is ready to take on
the town taking in a local drag show
featuring the best name drag queen i've
ever heard of patti o furniture this is
austin summers who we've seen in
episodes 1-3 here he's a struggling
playwright whose fellow drag queens
constantly mock him in fact the only
reason he's in town is one of the local
theater owners promised he could put on
one of his plays a theater owner who's
tragically killed by belle noire among
the drag queens we have a cameo by
famous drag queen eureka who's appeared
on several seasons of rupaul's drag race
she plays crystal decanter after a
rousing performance by patio whose
pearls and corset remind me of frank
inverter from rocky horror bell offers
him a black pill so that he can find the
highway of your true self the pill makes
him convulse and the interesting thing i
found here is that we get this quick
half second flash forward clip of him
snapping his fingers wearing the same
thing he wore the knight he killed
alongside belle and henry i'm not sure
if this pill can actually predict the
future or if these quick shots are
visions of what their future may become
we saw similar quick flashes occur with
alma after she took the pill in episode
2 showing her performing on stage with
an insatiable urge to feed belle takes
austin to crystal decanters where the
boys or queens are watching a rupaul
type show and enjoying some pizza and
beer and belle wastes no time shooting
the men and cutting one's throat so that
austin can feed while crystal runs into
the cemetery and who loves this cemetery
well it's our pal the pale man who makes
quick work of poor crystal decanter with
only two episodes left of the first part
of double feature it looks like the next
two episodes will focus back on the
gardner family i'm still hoping that
we'll get a tb karen backstory she and
mickey are probably my two favorite
characters this season and i'm hoping to
come out with an episode 5 preview
breakdown video later this evening so
make sure you're subscribed when that
comes out thanks for watching everyone
be sure to give the video a like and for
more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter and instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember
daddy loves you very much
you